okay so the topic of this video will be
the origins of life so let's go ahead
and get started well let's go ahead and
begin with the nebula hypothesis now
first of all what's a nebula well it's a
cloud of gas and dust in space now when
we say a cloud of gas the gases were
looking at our like hydrogen's and
helium gases that will eventually ignite
stars and nebulas are kind of given
these poetic little nicknames of the
birthplace of stars are a stellar
nursery and because this is where stars
and solar systems and planets form out
of art are the gases of a nebula here's
a few pictures of some nebulae that I
found that I just think are kind of
pretty you might have the user
imagination a little bit for instance
the Crab Nebula or the Eskimo nebula or
the hourglass nebula one of my favorites
right here is the Eagle Nebula if you
turn it maybe you kind of see the Eagle
shape a little bit if not what if I did
this put a little picture of an eagle
there and take away the Eagle does that
help well hopefully you can see why it's
called the Eagle Nebula and then one of
my favorites the Horsehead Nebula but
these nebula all have something in
common they're filled with hydrogen
gases and helium gases and eventually
stars and solar systems and planets will
form out of these gases and so that's
what the nebula hypothesis explains that
gravity here's our Crab Nebula again but
gravity will start to pull the gases
inward the hydrogen gas is the helium
gases pull of the gases inward and
eventually a star ignites and so here we
have you know start a Sun and then the
kind of the remaining materials kind of
forms planets and in our solar system
here you might know the four innermost
planets are the rocky planets Mercury
Venus Earth Mars these are the
terrestrial planets they actually
surfaces that you could walk upon but
the outer planets are kind of nicknamed
the gas giants Jupiter Saturn Uranus
Neptune they're their gases there's no
surface that we can land upon and
explore if we had the technology to do
that well when it comes to earth we can
say that the earth is approximately 4.6
billion years old and we know that from
the radiometric dating of rocks and
meteors that have landed on earth
so by examining the decay rate of
isotopes in rocks we come to 4.6 billion
years old
kind of a fun little side note here it's
estimated at around four billion years
ago bya in the picture means a billion
years ago the moon formed when young
ancient primitive earth was struck by a
struck by a planet sized body and that
collision resulted in the formation of
our moon so it's kind of an interesting
little side note there let's go ahead
and talk about ancient earth
first of all the Hadean era or the
Hadean Eon 4.6 - four billion years ago
well let's look at the climate here
incredibly incredibly hot very different
than today for a couple reasons why was
the earth thought - if you imagine this
artist's impression of the Hadean era
why do we think it looked like this well
number one the earth was constantly
being impacted by objects from space
early in the formation of the solar
system there's just a lot more meteors
and comets drifting around in space so
collisions were a lot more frequent than
they are today
not only that but from the evidence that
we find in really ancient rocks we are
we see that the earth itself was a lot
more volcanically active than than
currently today and so for these reasons
ancient earth we believe had a very very
hot but way too hot to support any life
when we when we examine rocks ancient
rocks we can kind of get a good idea of
what the atmosphere may have contained
for instance it's believed that there is
a lot of ammonia water vapor methane
carbon dioxide gases in the ancient
atmosphere and where did these gases
come from well many of the gases came
from for instance volcanoes even
volcanoes today are spewing out lots of
these particular gases here and another
place that water can come from well is
uh when comets crash onto earth you know
a comet is just basically a big frozen
block of ice and so when it crashes it
brings water now did all of the water on
earth come from comet impacts no a lot
of the water came from volcanic gases
like you see in this picture here steam
being released in and from this
particular volcano here well one thing
that's worth mentioning is that as
crucial as life
as crucial as oxygen is to life well
this was at a time when there was no
oxygen in the atmosphere well you think
about oxygen it's a byproduct of
photosynthesis things that do
photosynthesis would be like
cyanobacteria and algae and of course
plants but these organisms did not exist
yet so for if there's no life there's no
photosynthetic life there's no oxygen in
the atmosphere it's kind of an
interesting side note there well
eventually our ancient earth begins to
cool off and one of the reasons for the
cooling is earth is less and less
becoming less and less and less impacted
by objects from space and the Sun is one
of the big reasons for that the Sun I'm
sure you know is a lot more massive and
has a stronger gravitational pull than
the earth and so the Sun has been
gobbling up asteroids and meteorites and
another debris that's been drifting
around in the solar system for billions
of years so there's just less impacting
the earth as more time passes
kind of a side note here in 1994 this
was a kind of a big science story here
the shoemaker-levy comet was swallowed
up by Jupiter again some of the gas
planets have been have been impacted as
well and in 1994 we saw the
shoemaker-levy comet he absorbed and
swallowed up by Jupiter and as it got
closer and closer it breaks into these
fragments and it was really really
interesting so if you do a quick Google
search on the shoemaker-levy comet
you'll see some really interesting
pictures as these as these the comet
collided repeatedly the 21 fragments in
the Jupiter it's kind of a fun little
story to read about well another reason
why the earth eventually starts to cool
down is Earth is not nearly as
volcanically active as time passes the
volcanic activity slows and so the earth
is less volcanically active less
impacted by objects from space and so
the atmosphere and the planet begin to
cool down well if I were to ask you
clouds are a sign of which step of the
water cycle I hope you would say
condensation the process where water
changes from a gas to a liquid because
as Earth begins to cool we knew that
there is a lot of water gas water vapor
in the sky but it's too hot for it to
condense and fall as liquid but as the
earth begins to cool condensation
happens and so the water vapor condenses
all the vapor in the sky begins a
condensed and eventually as it cools
starts to fall as rain now this happened
over the course of millions of years of
course no one's implying that it rained
you know in one night but eventually our
oceans were formed as the water vapor in
the sky condensed and started to fall as
liquid rain
well it's shift focus here let's talk
about Miller and Urey Harold Urey
Stanley Miller two scientists from the
1950s at the University of Chicago they
performed it really really interesting
kind of a groundbreaking experiment so
let's look at their experimental setup
that they performed here they had a gas
chamber and inside they filled it with
gases that they believed were found in
the atmosphere of ancient earth billions
upon billions of years ago
so nh3 h2o ch4 h2 these are gases that
they inserted into the gas chamber now
why what are these gases
well the nh3 is ammonia the h2o is
simply water vapor the ch4 is methane
and the h2 is hydrogen gas now these
gases were thought to be in the
atmosphere of ancient earth billions
upon billions of years ago and then you
can see in the animation they added an
electrical spark to simulate lightning
an energy source that was available on
earth at this time and watch what
happens because of the energy from the
lightning from the electrical sparks the
molecules of ammonia and water vapor and
methane and hydrogen they're all broken
apart now what happens next is where it
gets hopefully really interesting in the
right hand side the lower right hand
side there's a little chamber where a
slimy film begins to appear after a day
or so and they start to chemically
analyze what is the slimy film that's
starting to appear on the inside of that
little container there and if I were to
put this this diagram up here and give
you a moment to look at it and I hope
you start to realize hey wait a minute
there's an nh-2 on the left that's an
amino group there's a co Oh H on the
right that's a carboxyl group oh that's
an amino acid
so upon examination they were able to to
produce building blocks of life amino
acids I think you should know are the
building blocks of proteins and
nucleotides which I hope you know are
the building blocks of nucleic acids
such as DNA and RNA now let me ask did
they produce life did they produce
living organisms out of the gases of
ancient earth and the answers absolutely
no not at all however it's really
interesting to think about what this
might imply so what this what this
really shows is number one that organic
molecules amino acids nucleotides
proteins nucleic acids these are organic
molecules organic molecules could form
from the ancient atmosphere and not only
that but quite possibly if this could
have been an early step that eventually
led to the formation of life on Earth
today and so that's kind of a a little
rundown here of the Miller and Urey
experiment okay so as we wrap up this
video right here if you're my biology
class try to answer these questions on a
separate sheet of paper and I'm happy to
check your answers before school or
after school one day thanks for watching